is a specialist on conflict resolution
and humanitarian Aid and an assistant
professor of public policy at the Doha
Institute of Graduate Studies T good to
have you with us again so look so the UN
Security Council finally has passed this
much watered down uh resolution to get
more Aid into Gaza but as hany was just
saying there uh in Rafa much
disappointment because it doesn't call
uh for a stop in the fighting Oxfam has
described the vote as a dereliction of
Duty by the UN to protect civilians what
did you make of it
Tam uh Daren I mean um
in essence when the UN was formed
especially the new UN after the end of
world war second world war it was
supposed to to tackle or prevent such
similar conflicts like the one happening
in Gaza but let's not forget I mean the
UN it's still it's a political
organization it's a it's an entity
that's controlled by powerful countries
mainly the V to power holders countries
so politics are there in every policy
and every little detail of the UN work
and sadly I mean we have have seen the
US in particular when it comes to this
to the Arab Israeli conflict always
siding with Israel losing its legitimacy
being even isolated marginalized as as a
powerful country in the world stage now
and it's it's uh it's again I mean it's
um if we want to wait for the UN to
resolve the Israeli I mean I don't think
the conflict will be resolved through un
channels anymore we need
bilateral bilateral politics we need
something like the the the quartet to be
revived again and and and and and and
look into the issues in Gaza pistan but
the UN is becoming irrelevant
marginalized very politicized and it
really and its mandate it's being
questioned now and that's that's an
interesting point you make about the
political power the political players at
the UN mean Russia for example just
minutes before that vote Russia
introduced an amendment to revert back
to the text of the original draft
calling for a ceasefire this was vetoed
by the US Russia argues that look the
current text gives Israel full full
freedom to clear out the Gaza Strip the
Russians are right aren't they of course
it's not it's not even about the Russian
it's about look at all the technocrats
in the UN including gues GES is not a
politician because he does not have a v
to power himself he's the head of the UN
look at experts like Albanese all these
un experts who have been saying or or
saying that what's happening in Gaza is
unicent has to be stopped immediately
and and investigated so you have the
bureaucratic level of the UN all saying
this is nonsense I mean you cannot uh uh
continue doing this we cannot keep
providing Aid under Israeli obstacles
there's so many obstacles to Aid
provision in Gaza I mean so what you
want people to be to be killed massacred
at the same time you feeding them
feeding exactly and at the same time I
mean when it comes to the practicality
and operational aspects of this
resolution I mean Israel is already in
charge of the viting process of Aid it's
limiting Aid amounts getting into Gaza
because it has def facto control of the
borders it's slowing Aid and it's it's
Bing every item what else the Israelis
want what what what what what other
guarantees do the Israeli want to to to
for them to be reassured that Aid is not
going to go in the wrong hand yeah and
this this whole issue of Aid provision
is really interesting isn't it because
it does biger the question how do you
then get more Aid into Gaza um to people
who as the World Health Organization
says are close to starvation if there's
no pause in the fighting I mean it you
know it begs the question is this
resolution going to make any real
difference on the ground
Tam uh sadly not I I I don't things I
mean we have we have there's a history
of previous even un resolutions on this
conflict in particular and Israel has
shows has totally ignored them so it's a
toothless resolution it comes with no
real mechanism to be enforced even in
its very weak format and shape now there
is no real mechanism to inform Israel to
comply even with the resolution as it
stands now so so just a final thought to
you then Tommy I mean the world food
program has warned a couple days ago
that Gaza is close to a devastating
famine uh if the war doesn't stop we
know over 20,000 Palestinian civilians
are already dead Israel says there'll be
no cessation of hostilities how do you
see things playing out then in the next
few weeks ahead into the new year it's
it's it's it's it's going to be very
awful I mean I mean yes the situation is
already dire you know many experts talk
about famine Etc it's it's I fear of an
explosion again like an explosion like
you know it's like yes so many analysts
talk about I mean we stopped talking
about the the the transfer scenario but
the situation reach reaches to a very
dark level where people have nothing to
survive on it's still there I can see it
as a real scenario and it depending on
how this is It's related to the conduct
of military operations in Israel if they
keep pushing South people will have no
option but to go south completely South
cross the border this time into Egypt
really good to get your thoughts and
your analysis thank you very much indeed
for your time